ooh all right I got a pair of fives what
why'd you bet so much I've got a full
house man bad luck hey ever wonder like
where these cards come from what like
the store no no like where they come
from you know what's their
history never really thought about it oh
well all
right the 52 card deck is a pretty
Universal Ally known object every
household in America and I would presume
most countries in the world has one or
two decks lying around their house
they're used for magic fortune telling
and most commonly for playing games but
this deck with four suits of two colors
numbers 1 through 10 and three face
cards per suit seems pretty normal to us
but where did it all come from let's
find
out
hello this is usually where I would put
a sponsored segment but I don't have one
this month so this video is brought to
you by my patreon go to patreon.com
generis papers or follow the link in the
description if you want patreon only
updates Early Access to videos and more
or if you just want to support me in the
work I do thanks a lot now back to the
video from a western perspective playing
cards here in in the historical records
of Europe in the mid1 14th century but
they weren't invented there writings
from the time refer to them as sarasin
cards which was a medieval word that
meant Arab or more broadly Islamic but
they weren't originally Islamic either
no to find the origins of these planing
cards we have to go further east to
China the evidence suggests that playing
cards in China existed as far back as
the Tang or Song dynasties in the 9th
and 10th centuries paper is fragile and
playing cards aren't usually kept in
good condition which is why we don't
have any physical examples of playing
cards from this time still we can be
pretty sure they existed and what they
looked like based on later examples of
Chinese cards Chinese plan cards often
called money cards had three suits coins
strings of coins and myriads of strings
they were styled after Chinese paper
money by the way the Chinese were the
first to invent paper money at first
these money cards were used as a money
substitute in other games in the same
way we use poker chips or even Monopoly
money if you look at playing cards even
our modern ones it makes sense that they
were modeled for money like our own
bills they have a number in the corner a
symbol next to it and in the center the
face of a ruler these money cards became
widespread in China and from there
spread to Korea and Japan where they
took on their own own characteristics
the cards also made their way through
the Silk Road to Central Asia then to
the Middle East there were many
varieties of cards in the Middle East
but the variety we're interested in were
the cards used in the courts of the
mamook Empire centered in Egypt these
cards looked like this beautiful right
and they had four suits chales Sears
coins and polo sticks Yes you heard
right polo sticks
the first Europeans to encounter these
cards or at least the first to emulate
them were the Italians sometime in the
1360s they kept the suits almost the
same with goblets coins and swords but
changed polo sticks to batons you see
polar wasn't a widely known sport in
Europe at the time any of you in the
audience with an interest in the occult
will of course recognize these suits as
they're the suits used in Tarot cards
though modern tarot decks swap out coins
for Pentacles and batons for wands to
seem more magical Italian and Spanish
playing cards still use these four suits
today they're called the Latin suits oh
and the pH cards or Court cards as
they're sometimes called are as we know
them now the Italians had a king often
mounted a queen usually enthroned and a
Nave which we noway call a Jack in Spain
the court was different there was no
female royalty instead a knight replaced
the Queen the first pling cards in Italy
were handmade and hand painted and were
bought and used by the upper classes but
cards did become popular with common
people and new methods were created to
produce the cards faster and cheaper it
was only natural that this new product
eventually spread West and North and the
next major development in European cards
occurred in Germany where new techniques
in printing meant Germany became the new
card capital of Europe German card
makers decided to ditch the Latin suits
of the Mediterranean to create a new set
one that was distinctly German they went
with hearts acorns leaves and Hawk Bells
German plane cards were not hand painted
instead they were printed either using
wood blocks or coer Engravings later
with the invention of the Gutenberg
printing press this became even more
streamlined during the late 15th century
French card makers switched from Latin
card designs to a simplified version of
the German suits that are now
recognizable today these simple shapes
could be printed even faster so these
French playing cards became the new
standard the French called their suits
Hearts clovers Pikes or spearheads and
floor tiles but once they made their way
to England the names changed heart
stayed the same of course but Pikes
became Spades which makes some sense a
spearhead and a shovel head are similar
shapes after all clovers became clubs
this one is strange but historians
figured that the Latin suits had been
known in England so the English kept the
name of this suit the clubs which by the
way was another word for batons instead
of switching the name to clovers or
leaves an odd choice to be sure but
we're stuck with it the tiles became
diamonds to us contemporary folk this
sort of makes sense but understand that
the word Diamond at this point did not
refer to this shape only the jewel so
yeah this shape which we now commonly
call a diamond actually comes from
playing cards the face cards went
through many iterations through time
with every card manufacturer having
their own designs but did you know that
the C cards were meant to depict
specific people well I say that but
traditionally the cards didn't depict
anyone specific but in France the four
kings queens and naves gained identities
that are still observed today at least
by people in the know let's start with
the Kings the King of Spades is David
the Slayer of Goliath and King of the
Israelites in the Bible Hearts is
Charles the great or Charlamagne King of
the Franks and depending on who you ask
First Holy Roman Emperor he is almost
certainly the most important King in
medieval history the King of Diamonds is
Julius Caesar he was dictator of Rome
and the most famous ruler in Roman
history and the King of Clubs is
Alexander the Great he was king of
Macedon and creator of one of the
largest land Empires the world has ever
seen on to the Queens the Queen of
Spades is Palace which is another name
for the Greek goddess Athena she was
daughter of Zeus and goddess of wisdom
BattleCraft and weaving
hars is Judith another biblical
character she is the heroine of the book
of Judith a book of the Old Testament
she wasn't a queen but she freed the
Israelites from Assyrian oppression by
tricking and beheading the general Hof
feres her heroic Act is famously a
subject of many masterpieces of European
art the Queen of Diamonds is Rachel she
was the wife of the biblical patriarch
Jacob and mother of Joseph one of the
most important figures in the Bible and
last is the Queen of Clubs aren she's
sort of an odd one arene is an anagram
for the Latin Regina which means Queen
some say that this was a nickname for
Charlemagne's concubine or it was
supposed to be ARA the mother of the
Greek hero Argus who built the Argo in
the myth Jason and the Argonauts or
maybe the French just couldn't think of
any more women in history I don't know
last the naves or Jacks they were all
named for milit AR men through history
and Legend the Jack of Spades was oir
the Dane a Danish Prince and Paladin of
King Charlemagne hars was laay the
nickname for etan de venol he was a
nobleman and military commander during
the Hundred Years War who fought
alongside Joan of Ark the jack of
diamonds was Hector the legendary hero
of Troy from Homer's epic The Iliad and
the Jack of clubs was Lancelot the
greatest Knight of the Round Table in
the Arthurian Legends and adulterous
lover to Queen Gwen the last Innovation
to our deck of cards was made in the
good old us OFA The Joker cards of which
there are two in each deck started
showing up in American decks during the
Civil War and were placed there
specifically for a game called uker they
are used in other card games though as
you know not very many they're so
uncommonly used that most people just
throw them away or misplace
them and that about wraps it up thanks
for watching my video if you'd like to
support me in the channel please
consider donating to my patreon the
links in the description below or leave
a like And subscribe thanks
[Music]
bye